بعد حوالي اربعه اسابيع من الاقتتال
الدامي تم التوصل لاتفاق جدا مبدئي بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع بجهود
سعوديه وامريكيه مشتركه مع اعتبر خطوه قد
تعبد السبيل امام اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
ووقف الاعمال العدائيه قبلت بردود فعل
مراحبه محليا واقليميا ودوليا
الخارجيه السعوديه قالت ان محادثات جده
ستركز على التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار
لنحو عشره ايام واوضحت ان الاجراءات
الامنيه في السودان ستشمل اليه لمراقبه
وقف اطلاق النار الاليه الثلاثيه رات في
الاعلان خطوه اولى مهمه صوب حمايه
المدنيين
واشارت الخارجيه الامريكيه الى ان احد
اهداف اعلان جده توجيه سلوك القوات من اجل
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه وان الخطوه
التاليه هي التفاوض على اجراءات امنيه
محدده
القوه المدنيه السودانيه رحبت بالاتفاق
بينها حزب المؤتمر السوداني الذي اعتبره
بدايه لوقف اطلاق نار دائم بالسودان
الموقف ذاته صدر من الجبهه الثوريه
السودانيه وغيرها من المكونات السودانيه
المبعوث الامامي بالسودان من جانبه توقع
استئناف مباحثات وقف اطلاق النار في اقرب
وقت
الاعلان المكون من سبعه بنود ابرزها
الالتزام بضمان حمايه المدنيين وتيسير عمل
المنظمات الانسانيه واحترام القانون
الانساني الدولي والقانون الدولي لحقوق
الانسان والالتزام بالتمييز بين الاعيان
المدنيه والاهداف العسكريه بالاضافه الى
بذل الجهود لنشر هذه الالتزامات داخل صفوف
طرفي الصراع على الارض هدوء حذر تتخلله
اصوات الرصاص بين الفينه والاخرى وكذلك
هناك توترات امنيه في بعض مناطق الخرطوم
والولايات اما حركه النزوح فلن تتوقف بحثا
عن مكان امن واخر احصائيه اعلنتها مفوضيه
اللاجئين تشير الى فرار حوالي 200 الف شخص
من السودان منذ بدء الاشتباكات وحتى الان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات